dollarin is removing fracture and Pearl
from the active duty map Pool and
replacing them with a brand new map and
a completely reworked Breeze and let's
just say some people really are happy
[Music]
much like CS go and Siege since they've
had enough maps to facilitate it
Valerian has had an active duty map Pool
for competitive play and last week Riot
announced on Twitter that both Pearl and
Fracture were being removed as of
episode 7 Act 2 and that they'd be
replaced by lotus and a new and improved
version of Breeze these changes and act
2's release will happen on Tuesday
August 29th right after Champions
concludes this weekend okay so let's
start with what's leaving I think that
it's pretty safe to say that the general
consensus among competitive players and
pro players is that they're pretty happy
to get a reprieve from playing Pearl for
a while the harbor Viper meta has made
the map a slog to play for a long time
and especially at the pro level it felt
pretty solved that said I will say it's
a little strange to make a change like
this just a couple months after the
alterations they made to the map and the
Nerf stay they made to Viper that really
reduced the ubiquity of this composition
but it is possible that everyone is just
so [__] tired of pearl that we all
need a break now on to fracture this is
where things get controversial because a
ton of the community is frustrated by
the fact that they chose to remove
fracture from the competitive game many
pro players and coaches believe that
fracture is one of the most important
maps for both Pro play and for the
competitive Labs some even went as far
as to say that this map promotes agent
diversity and gameplay diversity better
than any other map in the game which is
actually pretty anecdotally true right
you've got Evil Geniuses considered the
goats of fracture playing Sova on this
map you've got breach which is the
standard but then you've got teams like
DRX who choose to play Fade instead it
does sometimes feel like this map is one
that proteins can actually get creative
on and speaking of EG let's just say
they weren't exactly stoked about this
change either I just hope they don't add
ice box back and bring like I have a
love-hate relationship with Bree so it
doesn't it'll be fun to try it out but
sucks fracture is gone what's scattered
amongst these tears for the loss of
fracture were some people comparing
these choices to some of the other
options for removal ascent and Haven in
particular these are two maps that have
never left the competitive map Pool and
have been left largely unchanged by Riot
they truly are the standard for conch
Valley that said I don't know about you
guys but I wouldn't mind seeing them
swapped out here or there especially
assat which has the most ubiquitous
professional team come at Champions by a
lot people do seem to love it though so
I don't think it's going anywhere too
soon and finally we've got the map
that's coming back I would say that
actually the biggest news of this whole
announcement were the sweeping changes
they made to Breeze like this map is
totally new they've completely changed
all of mid made it much less of an a map
and made it much easier to creep up on
the attack side and put pressure on the
Defenders they also made significant
changes to both bomb sites and halls and
Eric and Kade both addressed all the
changes on stream the other day whoa
this is so much better
I like this
wow no more holes oh my God this is
amazing oh my God this is great this is
really good I think this is good it's an
insane difference though it's kind of
hard to say but it's definitely very
different
I'm just glad that Pearl and Fracture
are leaving honestly no matter where you
land on these particular changes I for
one am stoked that Valor has continued
to make changes to cycle maps in and out
of the game and been willing to go in
and tweak the maps they've already
designed like Tarik said Breeze looks
like a brand new [__] map and that is
dope to me another hilarious part about
this announcement for me was the cries
from all over the community to bring
back icebox a map that was once pretty
universally hated is now being longed
for and not just by fnatic fans and as a
box truther myself
I'm looking down for it another piece of
news to discuss before we go is that
apparently there's actually going to be
a brand new map allegedly called Sunset
unveiled this weekend on the Champions
broadcast many in the community are
pointing to these valorant tweets as
evidence that it's on its way what do
you think are you happy with no more
Pearl and Fracture is Ascent boring is
it the Box the best map in the game
let me know in the comments
what do I say about icebox is I know
that sometimes it can be boring to play
in ranked you know it gets you a little
bit of that seasonal depression I think
when you watch Pro play there's there's
literally no better map I think it's a
good map for like watching people pop
off which I think you know is obviously
an exciting part about the pro game so